♪ ♪ ♪
- San Diego, paradis
des surfeurs, deamamoureux
des plages et du farniente.
Mais dans ce décor
autant sur les plages,
dans les parcs magnifiques,
dans les lieux touristiques
et, bien sûr,dededededededededee
et du centre de San Diego,
les sans-abris se comptent
par milliers.
Pour se rendre compte
de la situation de plus en plus
critique, nous suivons
une infirmière qui sillonne
v v ville à la rencontre
des sans-logis.
Dans certains quartiere e e e eé
depuis deux ans.
Les causes sont maususususement
communes à toutes les grandes
villes.
Parmi les sans-abris qu'elle
rencontre, les histoires
plus d'emploi, plus de logemente
du désespoir.
Parmi les patients du jour,
il y a Sheila, dans la rue
depuis trois mois.
Problèmes de santé mentale,
défaillante... Un exemple
asmmmmmmmmun dans le travail
quotidien de Kristan.
Need medical attention tode e ee
Mitchell, un habitué.
manque de confiance en lui...
Son esprit n'est pas
toujours clair. Surtout
quand les services sociaux
à une foire d'emploi pour
essayer de le e e e e e la rue.
(en anglais)
Des trousses d'hygiène,
des kits pour traiter
les overdoseininininininininini.
Les travailleurs de rue f f f fà
cette croissance exponentielle
de pauvreté dans la rue.
Justement, ce matin-là,
nous rencontrons Rae, 40 ans,
enenenenenenenenenenenenenenenet
est assez simple.
Elle souhaiterait davantage
de douches disponibles
pour elle brbrbrbrbrbrbrbrbrbrbs
à San Diego s'approcherait
dangereusement des 10 000
selon certaines estimations.
Pour les commerçants,
cela n'a rien de réjouissant
pour l'image de la ville.
Selon ce conseiller municipal,
la solution passe d'abord
ceux qui peinent à payer
leur loyer et
sur le bord de se retrouver
dans la rue. La Ville
de refuges depuis deux ans
et veut lalalalalalalalanter
des "safe villages", sorte de
rassemblement de tentes.
En attendant le lancement
éventuel de ce projet,
se font déplacer deux foismamam,
afin de procéder au nettoyage
des trottoirs, où la t.t.t.t.t..
La Ville dit prendre
le problème à bras le corps,
Une ré,,,,,,,,,,
non seulement de la population
qui ne veut pas voir
près de chez elle, mais aussi
s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-abris.
L'infirmi t t t t t t t t t tour
L'infirmière complète son tour
de la vittttttttttttttttttttttto
pour un pèlerinage afin de
répandre les cendres de sa femme
dans les endroits qu'ils ont
taisisisisisisisisisisisisisisis
et s'est retrouvé dans la rue.
Il a quand même eu le temps
de renvoyer son fils de 19 ans
♪ ♪ ♪
L'envers du décor du rêve
californien n'est pa
mais on reste convaincu
que les projets d'aide
sur la table actuellement
permettront d'
Mais la tâche sera ardue.